vamos a hacer un par de ejercicios más
acerca de sonidos de revolución que
giran alrededor del eje de las 10 y
aunque estos ejercicios estarán un poco
más difíciles con suerte al acabar este
vídeo y si analizan los videos
anteriores y entienden todo van a poder
resolver cualquier examen que sea de
este tema o cualquier ejercicio de clase
o inclusive cualquier tarea que les
puedan dejar y bueno empecemos por hacer
una gráfica del problema que les quiero
contar supongamos que este es el eje de
las 10 y no creo que lo mejor lo voy a
borrar y voy a poner todo más centrado
para que se entiendan bien el problema
esto es mikel así es este es mi eje de
las equis y voy a tomar la función que
ha sido nuestro caballito de batalla
todos estos vídeos va a ser la función e
iguala x cuadrada y igual a x cuadrada o
dicho de otra manera si despejamos a x
obtendríamos que x es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de y esto es según lo que nos
convenga si nos conviene tomar una
función que sea con respecto a x
una función que sea con respecto al
bueno y ahora me voy a tomar una recta
constante arbitrario lo voy a tomar para
para hacer este ejemplo la recta igual a
4 esto me va a servir debido a que esta
recta me va a encerrar un área que yo
voy a hacer girar alrededor pero esta
vez no del eje de las 10 va a rotar
alrededor de otra línea constante pero
en unos momentos ustedes va a quedar muy
claro a lo que me refiero primero voy a
cerrar el área que voy a querer girar
entonces me voy a tomar dos puntos
arbitrarios me voy a tomar no sé me voy
a tomar el punto cero no no no quiero
algo más difícil me voy a tomar mejor el
punto uno va a ser este mi punto 1 y me
voy a tomar también el punto 2 en x todo
esto en x entonces este punto es el
punto 2,2 no no no no no el 22 no el 24
porque x es igual a la raíz de que y si
x vale 2 ya tendría que valer 4 además
estamos en la recta igual a 4 y aquí en
el 1 tenemos el punto 11 porque pues uno
es la raíz de uno bien y con estos
puntos ya tengo un área delimitada
área que está entre los puntos 11 14 y
24 la voy a colorear de color morado
claro para que ustedes se den cuenta de
cuál es el área que yo quiero rotar bien
y también les quería contar que no la
voy a rotar alrededor del eje las voy a
rotar alrededor de una recta constante
de hecho vamos a tomar la una vez voy a
tomar la recta constante x igual a menos
2 y aquí está el 2 por aquí están menos
2 y esta va a ser la recta constante es
decir esta recta x igual a menos 2 va a
ser mi eje de rotación en el cual va a
quedar ni área que estoy subrayando de
color morado dando así un sólido de
revolución esta va a ser mi eje de
rotación bueno y antes de meterme a la
parte de aje branca del asunto voy a ver
la parte más difícil de toda mi
ejercicio que es la parte de
visualización
voy a intentar dibujar les que está
pasando con esta área si ustedes tienen
un poco de imaginación ya estarán
pensando que es como un anillo pero es
un anillo extraño primero voy a dibujar
un círculo en perspectiva
voy a dibujar un cierto grosor este
grosor es plano es el grosor que me sale
al cortar yo este anillo por la recta
4 y después se dan cuenta por adentro
también es un borde que es plano por
adentro tenemos un borde plano y duro y
por afuera pues para fuera mi anillo
está cambiando se dan cuentas esta curva
que tengo yo aquí entonces mi anillo por
afuera por el borde de afuera es curvo y
antes de seguir con el dibujo también
voy a dibujar los ejes este va a ser mi
hija de leyes y no no no no no esto no
puede ser miguel así es lo voy a borrar
voy a intentar no lo está borrando oops
tengo un problema ya lo borré ya ahora
sí el eje la ya está más pegado a la
derecha porque construimos así
precisamente nuestra área nuestra área
está más pegada en un cierto borde en
una cierta parte a la derecha que a la
izquierda entonces este va a ser mi eje
de las yes y por aquí debe estar el eje
de las x por aquí estoy dibujando el eje
de las x y también esta recta la recta x
igual a menos 2 que es mi eje de
rotación es la que debe estar justo en
el centro
no resulta perdón debe ser esta red de
aquí darse cuenta que está recta si debe
de estar en el centro porque es mi recta
x igual a menos 2 y es la recta donde
fue el eje de rotación es decir mi área
que yo tengo coloreada va a girar con
respecto a esta recta esta vez tienen
que aceptar que no me quedó tan mal el
dibujo pero bueno ahora vamos a resolver
esto del método algebraico vamos a
utilizar el cálculo y para esto yo voy a
recordar el método de los casquillos voy
a suponer que este es el rectángulo que
voy a hacer girar alrededor de mi recta
constante para dar yo un casquillo
entonces este rectángulo tiene de ancho
de x como habíamos visto en él en el
vídeo de los casquillos y de largo quién
va a ser pues va a ser la función
superior que es 4 - la función inferior
que es x cuadrado es decir el largo me
va a quedar 4 - x cuadrada este va a ser
mi largo de mi casquillo bien entonces
ya tengo aquí este mi rectángulo que voy
a girar alrededor de la recta x igual a
menos 2
y pues vamos a dibujar el casquillo de
una vez entonces voy a tener que este es
mi borde superior este es mi borde
inferior
voy a dibujar la altura bien y ahora qué
sé yo de este de este castillo pues lo
primero que sé es que tiene un ancho de
x y tiene una altura de 4 - x cuadrada
es justo lo que acabamos de ver y de
escribir hace ratito y me preguntaba a
ser quién es el radio de este casquillo
en nuestro vídeo de el método de los
casquillos nosotros analizamos que el
radio era x pero aquí tengan cuidado el
radio no va a ser x por qué porque
además de x estamos tomando como
referencia a la recta x igual a menos 2
y se dan cuenta de aquí acá yo tengo 2
unidades y de aquí hasta acá yo tengo x
es decir que el radio va a ser lo voy a
tomar otro contador va a ser 2 más x la
distancia de la recta al origen y además
x 2 más x bien ya tengo el radio ya
tengo la altura ya tengo de x por lo
tanto primero vamos a calcular el
perímetro del círculo el perímetro del
círculo
ese tipo de radio pero que hace el radio
pues dos más equis y esto pues lo
podemos multiplicar de una vez estos
cuatro pin
2 x 2 x x 2 px y si ya tengo yo el
perímetro ahora lo que voy a buscar es
el área de la pared exterior pero como
sacábamos el área de la pared exterior
pues es muy fácil hay que multiplicar el
perímetro que yo tenía de mí
circunferencia y esto multiplicarlo por
lo alto de mi cilindro o de mi casquillo
entonces yo tengo cuatro más dos por
equis que era el perímetro ya esto hay
que multiplicarlo por 4 - x cuadrado
bien de una vez hagamos esta
multiplicación para que esta
multiplicación no lo estemos cargando
más adelante 4x4 es 16 p4p por menos x
cuadrada es 4x cuadrada negativo y ahora
sí 2 px por 4 pues es 8 px y 2 px por
menos x cuadrada me va a quedar menos 2
ping x
muy bien ya tengo una multiplicación y
por lo tanto ya tengo el área exterior
de este castillo y ahora para ello saca
el volumen había que multiplicarlo por
el ancho pero la anchura de x entonces
todo esto lo voy a multiplicar por de x
ahora bien como lo que queremos
realmente es el volumen de mis sólidos
de revolución hay que hacer la suma de
cada uno de estos casquillos o dicho de
otra manera la integral del nivel de
quien del volumen de uno de los
casquillos de x ya tengo yo la integral
pero ojo quieras van a ser mis límites
de integración como es una integral que
tiene que ver con respecto a x mis
límites de integración va a ser de 1 a 2
porque esa es la distancia que yo estoy
tomando en x del valor x igual a 1 al
valor x igualados y ahora que ya tenemos
la integral pues lo único que nos resta
es hacerla entonces voy a borrar un poco
mis dibujos y voy a borrar un poco mis
mis operaciones de antes para yo poder
resolver está integral bien esto lo voy
a borrar esto también que quede bien
borrado y ahora sí voy a trabajar con
esta integral para ella acá para este
ejercicio quien va a ser esta integral
pues bueno esa integral de 12 de 16 pib
que es la primitiva de 16 pi pues es 16
por x esta vez estoy integrando con
respecto a x entonces es 16 para x menos
cuatro para x cuadrada propuesta
integral de que es cuadrada pues es x
kubica entre 3 entonces me queda 4 x
cómica y todo esto dividido entre 34 y
entre 3 x x cúbica muy bien y después
tengo yo la integral de 8 px pero esto
es x cuadrado entre 2 es decir que el 8
con el 2 se dividen me queda 4 px
cuadrada y para finalizar esta integral
tengo la integral de 2 x kubica pero x
públicas u primitivas x 4 entre 4 y 2 /
x cuarta es un medio entonces me queda
pin medios x 4a todo esto evaluado de 2
a 1 y bueno vamos a evaluar primero
16 x 26 32 pin menos me queda 4 y entre
3 y 2 al cubo es 8 más 4 x 4 pues son 16
y menos 12 416 entre 2 son ocho por pi
pues son 8 pi este vídeo creo que va a
quedar muy largo y como ya estoy fuera
de tiempo y estoy haciendo todas las
carreras mejor no continuó en el próximo
vídeo